è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono la vj set oggi schamus
tommy ragazzi preparatevi perché oggi
siamo su un videogame e quelli che in
vita mia così senza se io dico sempre
che se dico spesso la frase senza senso
ma credetemi che questo non ha un cazzo
a che fare con tutto il resto e ve ne
accorgerete molto presto ci siamo su 8
dead è una cosa che non posso spiegarvi
a parole perché dovete vederlo per
capirlo perché inspiegabile tanto la
ragazzi in hd la grafica in hd alta
definizione queste sono le cinematiche
nuove altro che pixar il wake up dir
svegliate muore oggi è una grandissima
giornata sul sveglia questa mia mamma la
mattina e questo sono io la mattina sono
le tre le 349 che cazzo mi sveglio alle
3 49 donna lascia di dormire è la mia
mamma che si sveglia alle 4 mila 10 di
notte a tentare di mandarmi a scuola
illusa and smooth a questioni comandi
perfetto di andare avanti a perfetto
take two continua come ci piccoli
ragazzi spero che vi stia simpatico
perché un tizio simpaticissimo vedete
dallo sguardo si nota l'intelligenza ok
dato ragazzi non ha idea di come ci si
muove in sto giocando brema e bus del
mouse
ok ok ci siamo un punto io ragazzi cosa
cazzo sta succedendo a degli sbarchi
work to dial up gioca dal devo camminare
lì
ok come cazzo devi muovere anche l'altra
gamba zio nessun altro bravo ragazze di
picche ragazzi come questo e come si
cammina se vai a vedere ragazzi
praticamente sono io dalle quale la
mattina e poche parole press temi del
mouse button
c'è chi mi sembra il trucco i ragazzi ce
l'avete mai visto il polipo che si
trucca che ve ne ho capito se una piovra
un polipo sta cosa non lo fa bene unipol
posto del notte vi prenderli trucchi non
buttare tutto gioco ragazzo di cazzo sta
succedendo per mi devo credergli
prendere i trucchi zio non è difficile
mi sto trovando un comodino cosa ragazzi
stanno e queste sono scene vietate i
polipi minori di 18 anni e dobbiamo
uscire di qui devi devi no la porta la
porta la porta che cazzo fai già
possiamo seguire esatto non la dovresti
aprire coi piedi però con le braccia sei
le braccia si posso mettermi le dita nel
naso
ogni cosa a terra zione mi dice devi
devi andar giù grazie sopreso vinto
non so che cosa ho preso ma ho vinto va
bene così canzoni di ragazzi dove questo
tizio vengo la tua giacca in ostaggio
ragazzi devo foto il ricorso a quattro
ragazzi e non ho parole per descrivere
sta roba ma che cazzo mi avete
consigliato dove sto tizio che devo
biliare a calci dove eccoti magari amman
bambino e messi sul dischetto si prepara
il tiro fisso l'avversario con sguardo
seducente era la porta dirò no no non è
lo nell il pallone già possiamo fare noi
no e per distrarre la cassaria è tutta
una tattica 12 12 sul divano fiscal da
solo
ragazzi che cazzo sta facendo il primo
gol attenzione e polipi versus esseri
umani 10 giochiamo in casa ragazzi
giochiamo in casa letteralmente stiamo
giocando in casa siamo qua sul divano
pochi ragazzi bisogna tranquillizzare i
bambini che poverini quando si vince
contro di loro ci rimangono male quindi
li faccio capire che alla fine non conta
niente vincere fuga fuga lo vedi questo
1 tu quanto sei a quando 62 alberto 6 ha
detto la mamma che adesso me lo da me le
caramelle i regali di natale suo cast
gancia la chiave lui ridotto anche
battuto bravo altrimenti dico la mamma
che è copiato tutti i compiti appena
arrivi a casa tante botte sul culetto
che faccia a guardar riguarda la tv ne
sono si sa cosa fa sono entrato sono
entrato nel televisore cosa ragazzi sta
succedendo qualcosa non capito cosa ma
sta succedendo grande al mio telecomando
fantastico bravo così vedete che c'è
qualcuno che capisce il tuo mondo
cos'è la bici moto ho chiamato guardi un
programma di cucina dove cucinano i
pesci e sei un polipo cioè come se
guardasse un programma dove cucinano
esseri umani non ha senso cioè uomini
con le cuffie va beh non importa vai
così ragazzi e lui è l'uomo nuovo cuoco
lo sapevo mi sta guardando st mi sta
guardando a come una con aria appetitosa
mi vuole mangiare forse perché ho
vomitato ragazze che senza a sto gioco
credo tra l'altro ragazzi che quello sia
l'acerrimo nemico di yocto del cuoco
credo sia così
mi pare di aver visto così nelle
anteprime del gioco qualcosa del genere
comunque va bene
l'importante che ci siamo andati
[Musica]
ragazzi questa questa la moglie di otto
dead
ma che cazzo che ha fatto fare a di
sposare un polipo e triste triste perché
gli ha portato una banana giusto puoi
averla fatta bello ragazzi ho sempre
sognato di ricevere una banana da mia
moglie accetta la banana in fila della
incamera avvicinarmi al lavandino e
pulire i piatti ragazzi sto facendo tu
arkin di miley cyrus
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e ora di mettere un po d'ordine in
questa cucina maledizione saliva gordon
ramsay mi fa un culo tanto quindi meglio
che prenda la scopa e tenti di spazzare
come si deve poi zio è questo ragazzo il
modo migliore per pulire una cucina
donna impara hai visto donna questo è il
tuo uomo romantico che pulisce le cucine
al posto tuo ragazzi guardate come mi
guarda con aria sensuale perché la sto
ipnotizzando con i miei sensi sexy se
volete lezioni su come rimorchiare le
ragazze
chiedete a me perché io vedi come vedete
ragazzi le conquiste in un attimo a
molti di voi credono che le donne siano
attratte dai regali romantici dalle
degli anelli da ste cose qui ma la vera
cosa che piace alle donne ragazzi è un
cetriolo amore mio lo so che sono la
persona più romantica che tu abbia mai
conosciuto in tutta la tua vita guarda
con lo fissa bellissimo io ti offro un
cetriolo e tu mi offre una banana
insomma stasera ci divertiamo tutti e
due ragazzi sto gioco è fottutamente il
massimo voglio vedere che cosa c'è di
guar stanza dei bambini stanza dei
bambini dove cazzo stai andando del
fermo siamo cos'è e tua figlia quella ma
è la immaginavo un po più poli portai
tranquilla piccola mia e la mamma che
stasera andiamo a giocare quella banana
il cetriolo a guardà nell'armadio se ci
sono dei mostri a perfetto non riesce a
dormire perché ci sono mostri
nell'armadio quanta ragazzi devo
guardare nell'armadio perché sono non so
che cazzo sta succedendo sfondando tutto
un buongiorno 6 cent a lei buon uomo io
non so che cazzo ci sta facendo qui
dentro ma questa è proprietà privata si
levi dai [ __ ]
octopus
[Musica]
oddio è un ninja è un ninja adesso
stanno piovendo unicorni arcobaleni non
uso le scale che sono troppo mestre in
fatemi scendere così stessi ancora
spaventata racconta a trova un libro
delle storie e racconta gliene una per
calmarla devo trovare un libro per
raccontare una storia e non credevo di
arrivare a tanto nella mia vita ma posso
farlo perché è mia figlia abbiamo supera
braccio fantastico sto libro animali
squartati far peggio di dire che un
libro per una bambina post può essere
perfettamente animali animali squartati
perfetto ragazzi dove come cazzo perché
ci siamo allora è allora sediamoci
tranquillamente perfetto perché mi sono
addormentato york lo fa senza basso che
papa si addormentano quando raccontano
le storie alle bambine ma non credi di
perché ce l'hai duro senti 8 de balzati
un attimo bravo
ok molla libro allontanati dalla stanza
per favore perché non so perché la carta
simone non lo fa fatemi saline di qua
perché non voglio usare le scale sono un
padre esemplare non potete non
riconoscere melo
mio zio entrato mi sono incastrati
simone la porta [ __ ] la porta chi
l'ha inventato e ste stronzate ci sono
un call ci saranno un casino di altre
cose da moretti si cura con che ragazzi
per anziché un tuo dove perché ho fatto
un casino di sfide con questo gioco io
ve lo dico losco amando da da morire
perché non ho mai visto una cosa così
senza senso ma nel complesso è veramente
fantastica ovviamente tutto ciò che un
genio comunque direi che per oggi
possiamo concludere qui seguito è
piaciuto comer solito ragazzi lasciate
un commento vi piace anche la voglia di
facebook e come noi miei entrate nella
descrizione
discrete velici vediamo un pasto vinto
bene ragazzi